let me let me tell you guys a story so i
i applied for a mortgage
and i talked about this last week but i
think with you know with clint here
uh i applied for a mortgage months ago
to to get a small house nothing nothing
too crazy expensive like actually just
small
uh single family i think it's like two
bedroom two bath and
the first weird thing that happened was
they started juggling agents on me
agent kept changing they kept demanding
the same paperwork over and over and
over again it was like hey we need your
pay stubs hey we need your tax return
hey we need they asked me to write a
letter hand write a letter explaining my
job and my business and what i do and
i'm like okay this is getting weird
and then finally after three months they
come back and say oh your credit score's
too low
my credit score is impeccable it is
almost as high as it could possibly be
my income is fantastic and it was very
strange to get denied this
but what it seems like you almost went
full trump there i thought you're gonna
go
tremendous tremendous uh but talking to
my family and friends they're like
it seems like they're trying to stop us
from buying property
meanwhile blackrock right many other
investment firms wall street pension
funds are buying up property and
outbidding people
so i i don't understand why it is that
they did
they went through all this and uh gave
us the runaround
but you know what i said i was on the
phone with this with this company i'll
leave them nameless for now
i they were like look i was like hey you
know the information you claimed about
my credit score is false
and defamatory and i actually want to
know how this happened
because if you guys issue false credit
statements that could seriously impact
my
ability to buy property and it's not
true and i want this corrected
immediately
this lady is like let me find someone
for you and then i was thinking about it
i was like why would
a lender do something like this
unless they couldn't admit they didn't
have liquidity
to actually issue loans or they were
near insolvency
and so i said on the phone i was like is
your company
nearing insolvency no no no absolutely
not and i was like i just find it
interesting how long and hard
i've been struggling with with the the
run around
you know to try and get this alone i
just kind of feels like something must
be wrong behind the scenes and they
don't want to publicly admit it like
they may be nearing insolvency no no no
no um actually you know i'm going to put
you on hold for a minute
and see if i can find someone and they
put me on hold for like 15 minutes
i was like i wonder if i struck a chord
you know i'm making assumptions but i
have to wonder i started thinking about
this
there's a year no one paying mortgages
is it possible that all of these people
who had loans did not pay them back
because they couldn't
and the bank is sitting on bad debt well
black one things blackrock's buying is
more
mortgage-backed securities same thing
that they did in 2008 is there they're
buying up massive amounts of them i just
rather you actually you said you had
some
expertise in the whole thing like why
would someone with good credit be get
denied alone in this day and age well
there's there's a multitude of factors
when it goes to conventional lending
i was in the private lending field so
basically as a hard money broker
i i took private investor capital and i
would lend it out to real people so like
i'm the actual guy who cares basically
what banking used to be and what it
should be
is someone in the in the middle that
cares about the capital on one side and
the borrower on the other because
they want to pair it together they don't
want to get sued they want everything to
work out
in the end and the investor gets a
return that they can appreciate
however with the the conventional
lending side it's complete nonsense
there the
basically it's just so deeply regulated
that you can have
these these these windows that you have
to fit through perfectly
or you can get turned down and this is a
complete opposite of what it used to be
in 2004 2005 whereas if you had a pulse
at that point
you could get qualified for a million
dollar loan and you could just lie about
your income it didn't matter
it's now completely the opposite now
okay go ahead i had a loan with them
already
yes and i got along with them recently
within the past i think like eight
months
the only thing i could think of i mean
you
if you're right and they're insolvent i
would be stunned simply because
the federal reserve has no i don't
really think they're insolvent
right i'm just saying i wonder if
they're sitting on bad debt so they're
like what do we do we got all these
loans and no one's paying back
blackrock comes in and starts buying up
all these houses
could it be that that's a pseudo bailout
when people all start trying to sell
their homes because they couldn't pay
for them
and then blackrock comes in and covers
the debt plus
i look at it from a totally different uh
perspective actually the the inventory
is so low across the country
right now there's uh last i looked there
was only a million houses for sale
normally there's four to six million
which would be a standard clearing time
of about six months
so we have one to two months worth of
inventory the prices are skyrocketing
simply because the demand
outpaces supply it's not there's no
conspiracy there however
the reason we have that situation is
because of the foreclosure and eviction
moratoriums
which are a product of the lockdowns
which the government is responsible for
and then the fed is juicing the system
by putting seven trillion
dollars out there and of course you're
going to ch you're gonna
you're gonna be forced to chase yield in
a way that is very reckless
and we are we are laying the groundwork
for the greatest real estate bubble in
our history
i promise you that and give it four or
five years
at most in my opinion you could go to
liberty lockdown you could tell me if
i'm wrong
four to five years from now but be very
cautious so are you saying people
shouldn't be well you're not
giving advice but you think it's dumb to
buy a house right now i think it's
it's sane in the short term because
inventory is so low and the regulatory
environment is so
challenging to be able to build it's
going to be it's going to be a year plus
before you get these huge waves of
housing and then you also because of the
lockdowns you you destroyed the supply
chain so you have all of these shortages
and materials which is
ultimately adding to the price of real
estate because that's what it costs to
build it yeah so
they're all the way around though this
is what bothers me about i saw this this
clip that was really it was a great clip
it was tucker carlson with this uh this
reporter guy that
did it did a really eloquent takedown of
all this
but ultimately in all of his soliloquy
did not mention the federal reserve once
the federal reserve is responsible
for so much that is destroying this
country right now
and it doesn't get any talk like none
and it's
and it's it's frustrating to me because
it seems as if
you almost get into alex jones territory
when you bring up the federal reserve
no it is a legalized cabal of bankers
that control this
i mean the world but moreover this
country and this economy but hey they're
lgbtq and non-binary friendly as they
announced recently so
uh they're perfect for criticism so what
you're saying is that you're a bigot
well you know no no i'm on your team no
no hold on tim i would counter your
narrative
because i don't think blackrock would do
anything for the benefit of the united
states especially with their record with
their history
of getting bailouts whenever they have
losses and
keeping the profits whenever they have
profits this is what blackrock is
and we have to remember in 2008 that
large
huge economic reckoning was just a burp
was just a small bubble a part of a
larger indigestion problem
that there's no pet no bisnol fall for
and
this is only going to be so much more
worse because in 2008 this larger
problem
wasn't rectified wasn't fixed it was
paid over with more debt
with a bigger bubble and that bubble's
gonna going to pop up sooner or later
only thing you needed to do
was let the bad actors fail that's all
you had to do
and they refused and what do we have now
the the most egregious
moral hazard in history you have
blackrock and all of these other guys
and going out so let's not forget bill
gates the largest landowner in all of
the united states
of course and so so they're going out
and they're buying real estate at any
price because they can't find yield
because the stock market is also in a
bubble because of the trillions that the
fed has printed
and now you have young people who are
priced out of housing that feel hopeless
that are suicidal you've also locked
them in their house for a year so i
don't even blame them for feeling
suicidal
and none of this gets blamed on the fed
we could have never locked down this
country for a year
if not for the federal reserve because
you couldn't have papered it over like
you did
so every single layer of this falls at
the
doorstep of the federal reserve and no
one talks about it and it drives me
crazy so what you're saying is uh by
bitcoin
yes actually i am yeah i am saying that
well i'm good if there's a bubble like
you're saying a six year
bubble from now housing bubble what
would it look like year by year what
would change
it it's very hard to say because it all
right so this is this is what i tell
people when they ask me for advice
because i am a long-time real estate
investor
it's very important that you pay
attention to short-term interest rates
obviously if the federal reserve hikes
rates we're in serious trouble so i
don't think they're going to do it
simply because they can't
they cannot do it because our debt is so
massive if they increase the rates at
which the government has to borrow we
are insolvent as a nation
so the alternative is that you see bond
bond vigilantes come in and they they
stop buying long-term
uh bonds in which case you see interest
rates hike basically all i'm saying is
this
if you see 30-year mortgages or 15-20
whatever
that get north of four and a half five
percent
expect to see the fissures that are
underlying this economy
start to really show so what does it
look like in four years
it depends on the interest rates i mean
it really does like this is why i
keep federal reserve sets well they do
when they don't they set
short-term interest rates long-term
interest rates are set by bond buyers
bond buyers are china the american
people many people buy bonds so
it's not it's not as simple as that
people always think like well if they
hike rates or if they don't hike rates
this
this lasts forever no because at some
point housing no matter how cheap it is
because you can
you can get you know 3 30-year money
well we have an inflation rate of five
percent
what logical sense does that make as an
investor why would you ever
lend out money at less like basically
slightly more than half of the inflation
rate you are assuring yourself capital
destruction
and yet people are doing it but the
reason they do it is because they
believe that the federal reserve will be
the buyer of last resort
when it comes to those bonds that's the
reason that it persists they're
expecting a bailout
yes they are and it's a good bet and
they should yes and they should yep
and and they and the fed should expect a
revolution
if if i have anything to say about it i
don't i don't i don't no i think they'd
be smart
peaceful no i think most people most
people are just going to grumble and
demand a higher
minimum wage well they're the fools yeah
they're the useful idiots because
if you still think that that's the
reason that you're not getting paid well
enough and that's the reason you can't
afford a house
all of this is a product of your
currency being destroyed year after year
for a hundred dollars you know what
really blows my mind about bitcoin is
like every time i tweet about it i get
someone who's arguing from 2011 like
as if they got into a time machine or
like if they fell asleep
under a tree and grew a really long
beard and woke up and opened twitter and
then commented i'm like bro it's been
10 years i put money into bitcoin like
six years ago i'm
very happy with my store of value yeah
well it's not a currency i don't care
if i put money my money in the bank i
would have lost half of it by now or
whatever the stupid number is
the actual number of inflation so i
bought bitcoin
wish i bought more and they're like yeah
well look it fell 50
bro i bought in november it's up 300 and
something percent stop
looking at it and and it's it's it's
insane okay i'll tell you what
go put your money in the us dollar
because the story i always tell
everybody i went on amazon
click the little tab but i was like i
need a tablet for the house forgot to
buy it
a few days later i opened up amazon it
said alert i clicked it price change for
this product jumped up 130 bucks
amazing that's a huge huge shift it's
incredible was it like a 15
increase in cost or something while
bitcoin went up 15
in value so we we have a shed full of
wood
left over from the skate parks and it's
probably like i'm sitting on a gold mine
yeah
yeah it's like 10 grand seriously it's
like it's it's
no no joke it is a shed full of wood and
lumber
of various sizes fantasy at the time
at the time it was probably a thousand
dollars it's probably like six seven
thousand dollars of lumber right now
what has it been like as a builder
i was just gonna say i'm building six
houses right now fortunately we started
buying
our our materials as the planning was
getting near the you know the
vertical stage where you start to
actually build but yeah i'm getting
crushed
i'm getting crushed but the the
fortunate thing for me is the end market
will end up paying me off
anyways because the market has increased
so much it's up 15
year-over-year nationwide in san diego
it's even higher than that
uh florida like basically any of the red
states where
people have have fled the blue states to
you know go and
have some semblance of freedom the
market some of those markets are up 50
75 i was just in florida and i was
trying to help a friend and some family
members find
anything there it's virtually freaking
impossible right
now because the prices are just going up
so
high i i was just flabbergasted and all
these real estate guys are like yup
this is utterly insane i have never seen
this uh high of demand
i heard one guy saying it's gonna go
down in 16 months other people are
saying no that's not going to happen but
but
it's virtually impossible and at the
bitcoin conference which was also
happening
in florida in miami there was a lot of
talk about the federal reserve about the
banking cartel that's why i love the
biggest
and there was 12 000 people with with
all these conversations going along and
the big conversation was we need to get
away from this financial tyranny
that's happening right now that you know
inflation is a tax on savings if you're
stuck you know having us dollars
in your hands or underneath your bed
those dollars are
slowly liquidating those dollars are
slowly going away and you don't even
realize it the purchasing power of the
dollar look up that chart
go on duckduckgo click purchasing power
of
dollar and click images and you will be
shocked come on man
you know we're not raising taxes on
anybody unless you make more than
four hundred thousand dollars families
it's only
four hundred thousand dollars meanwhile
we're going to
print seven trillion and we're going to
borrow 20 something trillion and pump it
into the system which will devalue all
of your savings
and strip away your resources and buying
power without you even realizing it
because if you did realize it
you'd probably go outside with a
pitchfork part of a bigger problem a
part of a bigger
uh solution which is brought to us by
the g7 recently
with their build back uh better proposal
which they announced that they're going
to try to get 40 trillion dollars
on infrastructure and as we know the
term infrastructure very loose term very
generalized term
but when when you see the government
intervene so dramatically
when you see them print money out of
thin air we have to understand
the american people need to wake up to
the fact that when this happens
they are getting robbed blind and the
government is literally coming to your
house as you're sleeping going through
your money taking it from you
slapping your wife upside the head
kicking your dog and saying
give me more and then american people
are like yeah sure yeah yeah give us
more
and then it's just there's this meme
going around that that i shared
today of a clown saying hey we're going
to give you free stuff and then he opens
up this
this prize box and it's a gun to the
person's head because that's essentially
what it is when you get promised free
stuff
it's your servitude it's your financial
tyranny it's you being robbed
blind naked uh to the point where
people are finding it extremely
difficult to make ends meet
and harder and harder to own anything
and this again plays into this bigger
great reset agenda which is essentially
carried out with the same generic
talking points of buildback better which
is all these globalists keep repeating
and talking about
isn't bacon up like 20 that sounds right
yeah
every year lumber's up 400 i mean this
is this is
wild stuff but bacon well yeah i know
bacon's more important but
uh no it's true and you know peter
schiff is wrong about bitcoin but he's
right about this
he's right that not his analogy used to
be
that america is a heroin addict and debt
is our
is our heroine i would like to add to
his analogy and say that
it's actually the globe that's where
that's where we are now
because we went from i think it was 19
trillion before
trump and national debt were approaching
30 trillion by the end of this year
i estimate personally even though the c
the cbo says it'll be 40 trillion by the
end of 2030
i think it'll probably be closer to 50
trillion nationally we have over
not naturally globally we have over 200
trillion in debt unfunded liabilities in
america are about 100 trillion
i mean you go down the list and it's
like this is such it's so
clearly a house of cards and the most
important thing i want people to
understand is it's not
new it's not new the savings alone
crisis the
tech bus the 0809 bus even even before i
was born
we have the entire purpose of the
federal reserve
is that you can have malinvestment and
then at the end of the day you can bail
yourself out
and who who is actually bailing yourself
out we are the people that pay taxes
not these sensitives that are profiting
and taking billions that's
that's really the the scam here and and
because we don't understand it
we have people that we have the marxists
that think that it's it's capitalist
greed that's the issue and you have the
republicans who think that it's
immigration that's the issue and that's
why they can't get ahead and that's why
they can't own a home
you're both wrong you're both seeing a
portion of the elephant you're not
seeing the whole thing
i want to add the debt to that analogy
as i have eloquently before
and i would say the federal reserve is a
toothless crack [ __ ] on fentanyl
to add to all of this uh a part of the
larger context and when you start seeing
things from that perspective
it actually makes sense that's offensive
to crack [ __ ] though it is i apologize
yeah these are people
these are people who who need help and
compassion the federal reserve is like
you ever see that subreddit evil
buildings it's just oh yeah
someone should put the fed on that
subreddit just a picture of the federal
reserve
each and every one the sad thing is i
don't think many people would get the
joke
they wouldn't even recognize the
building full building i like i would
say that the the debt
federal reserve debt is the heroine and
then the interest on the debt is the
methadone
that you need to get off the heroin but
unfortunately in this situation you
it's their methadone so if they don't
want you to have it and the reason the
metaphor works so well is because
ultimately the debt the the heroin
you're taking
you have to take more and more just to
not get sick that's where we exist today
and and the reason that the collapse um
in 0809 was so severe is because the
debt
was significant at that point we have no
idea what is coming
with this next collapse i am telling you
because the debt is so much more
uh you know just severe than it was even
10 years ago
and there was there is no paul volcker
that exists in politics today that's
going to come in and do the right thing
and hike interest rates to 22 like he
did in 1981 it's not
it's not gonna happen and i know that
seems crazy because
we've existed with three and a half
percent mortgages this i'm talking about
fed funds rate was over 20 percent that
dude is a
animal and what what happened with that
i mean people stopped buying or what two
years severe recession and then we had
30 years of the greatest economic boom
in human history he's a hero for that
he's a bad guy in a lot of other ways
but what he did with that was incredible
because 70s were very much like what
we're experiencing now
high inflation and he was like we ain't
playing this he's a bill he's a build a
burger
i had a very interesting conversation
because he was lost in the building and
i was trying to help him find his way to
the vip area as i was questioning him
about bill defer
he seemed super stoked about it he was
really nice
he was actually a very cordial guy and
he actually let me in the room to ben
bernanke
and i went up to ben bernanke and i
asked him how does it feel to steal the
most amount of money in recorded human
history from
uh the working class and he literally
tried to rip away the microphone from my
hands
you're officially my hero you actually
i'll send
ben bernanke there's like three
confrontations he gets really angry when
he gets confronted
also a bilderberg member just a side
note when you bernanke yes you went
skydiving with remember
oh yes we and me and and tim made a
video about ben bernanke because
yeah people are like there's no way
you're confronting all these guys this
is impossible
so luke was accused of being a spy like
working for
a bunch of like dick cheney and tony
blair
because luke was able to confront
bernanke like in a private event
so there were all these posts on reddit
there were like it's no there's no way
this is possible
luke is controlled opposition so uh we
put together a video where luke's on the
phone
or like no you're chilling and your
phone rings yeah and i think i think
your brother made the photoshop images
of me and ben bernanke with strippers
and skydiving
so what happens is luke's luke's sitting
there and then his phone
rings and it's like it says ben bernanke
and he's like benny what's up
and then the camera's panning to like
background stuff and there's there's a
photoshop
of of luke and ben bernanke skydiving
together and then he's like yeah i need
some more what did you call them
federal reserve fiat slave notes or
something and you're like
i'm going to say you're slapping it yeah
yeah yeah i'll just i'll pretend to
question you
you'll act flustered it'll be great
we'll make a bunch of money bernicke
said that there was no chance of a
housing collapse
about 18 months before it happened yeah
but you know why they want people
to they want the poor people to keep
buying you're absolutely
they're sneaking out the back door
absolutely right that's that's the
mistake that people make is they always
assume
how could they be so bad isn't it their
job to evaluate economics
how could they have gotten this wrong
because it's the that's what they're
there to do
they're there for you to be the buyer of
uh that holds the bag
while all of their cronies get out the
back door that's what it's always been
and yet we allow this to persist i just
want to really emphasize this point
why are we allowing this to persist it's
if you because you've got republicans
who sit on their hands and democrats who
set things on fire
i don't know it's ignorance it's like
it's like it's like
intentional obfuscation there's this
henry ford quote i came across it's well
enough that people of the nation do not
understand our banking and monetary
system for if they did i believe there
would be a revolution before tomorrow
morning yes that was like the 30s or 20s
or something
it's been going on since they formed the
federal reserve basically that's a good
question arguably even before i think
uh andrew jackson was terrified he broke
up the central bank in the 1850s
and got an assassination attempt against
jefferson advised against it as well
so they put his face on another bill
yeah he said that he said that uh
national banks would be more dangerous
than a standing army i mean these guys
got it
they got it because this isn't new
that's what i keep going back to it's
not new it has happened and it's lasted
far far before the federal reserve the
federal reserve was just the best at it
and damn were they good at it because
they got it done in the dead of night
and no one knew about it and they have
been doing it for 110 years
that's right good for them yeah because
it's just raw talent and ability i
applaud you and
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you